[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: With that very
humbling introduction
let's get a round of
applause for Bobby Braun.
BOBBY BRAUN: Wow.
I'd like to meet that guy.
He sounds really impressive.
Thank you.
First of all, thanks to
Google for hosting all of us
here today.
The campus that you're building
here in Boulder is beautiful.
And we're all very happy
to have you in our city
and in our state.
As was said, my
name is Bobby Braun.
And I'm the dean of the
College of Engineering
and Applied Science at the
University of Colorado Boulder.
We are among the fastest
growing engineering colleges,
and we're actually one of
the most diverse colleges
of engineering in the country.
And that's something that we're
really proud about because it
allows us to reach out and
partner more with industry
in our state, including Google.
I'm a Mars guy.
I guess, maybe, a
Martian in my blood.
And I've worked on a
number of NASA missions.
And typically, I work with
engineers and scientists
on what it's like to build
and send spacecraft to Mars.
But today I'm here with a really
interesting group of people,
people who I've had
the pleasure to work
with for a number of years now
in what's been a groundbreaking
television series
put on by National
Geographic with executive
producers Ron Howard and Brian
Grazer.
And I got to tell you,
working with these people,
it's been like a family.
And for me as an engineer,
perhaps the best thing
has been working with--
not with other engineers--
[LAUGHTER]
--but with artists
and film studies
folks, actors, writers,
and big thinkers
from across the spectrum
that have been part
of this innovative docudrama.
How many of you have seen any
of the episodes, season one
or season two?
That's a good number.
It's a good number.
Season two is
going on right now.
We just last night-- episode
four was premiered on Nat Geo.
They're showing on
Monday nights, 9:00 PM.
You can catch up with those.
And you can actually
see episode five and six
that have yet to come out.
Tonight on our
campus at CU Boulder,
we'll be premiering
episode five.
You can see it on campus a
week before it will actually
be shown worldwide.
So that's what we're
all here today.
We're here for this
event, and then
for this evening's
event in Boulder.
I'm here today
joined with a number
of the members of the show
in various capacities.
Going from my--
going down this way--
I always mess that up.
STEPHEN PETRANEK: Your left.
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY BRAUN: Well, it's my left.
But it's their right.
Let's do it that way.
The person who corrects
me the most in my life
is actually Stephen
Petranek, who over the years
has been a great friend.
Stephen is a co-executive
producer of the series.
And in fact, the series
is based on a book
that Stephen wrote years ago
about how we will actually live
and settle the planet Mars.
He's really the creative
genius behind the whole series,
if you will, through his book.
And it's wonderful to have
you here in Boulder today.
Next to him is
Antonia Juhasz, who
is an expert in oil
and energy policy
and has written numerous papers
and given numerous forums
on those topics.
In this series,
she's a big thinker.
So this is a series, right,
that goes back and forth
between the present
and the future, right?
So we talk about what's
happening in our world today,
and then we flash
forward from that
into how that might portray
into a human settlement of Mars
in the future.
Antonia has been wonderful
in providing insights
about climate and
energy and policy,
international policy
issues here on the Earth
and how those might--
those same kind of issues
might play out on Mars.
And then next to her is actually
an award-winning writer,
Leonard David.
Who, if you're in the space
community like I am, Leonard
needs no introductions.
But Leonard has
written a book that
is a companion book to the
National Geographic series.
If you're interested, you can
pick one up on the back table
there.
But Leonard's book is a great
companion to the series.
It provides wonderful
context about past, present,
and future Mars exploration.
And so we're here today.
What we're going to
do is we're going
to watch the trailer
from season one,
just to bring you up to
speed about what happened
two years ago during season one,
which took place in the 2030s.
Then we're going to show
the trailer for season two.
Before I do, there's
two other folks
I definitely want to
introduce very quickly--
in the audience, who will be
speaking tonight on campus.
And they're actors in
the Nat Geo series.
And that's Sammi Rotibi--
maybe, Sammi, you
want to stand up--
--and Evan Hall.
[APPLAUSE]
And as someone who's
consulted on the show
and worked with
some of the writers
and actors in the
production of the show,
you know, they've
been fantastic.
These guys-- it's just
their roles are so--
it's amazing how well they've
suited into these roles.
I know they each have an
engineering background,
and you know, you have
multiple engineering degrees
from CU Boulder.
I'm just kidding.
But from watching
you all on the show,
I mean, one would
think that you did.
And it's actually amazing.
SPEAKER 2: I spoke to you
before the season started.
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY BRAUN: Yeah.
So it's been a lot
of back and forth,
getting ready to do that.
But that's what's
made this show,
I think, so unique is that it's
a scientifically honest show.
It's a scientifically
accurate portrayal
of what the future
might look like
based on what's happening
right now in space exploration.
So what we do is
jump into the clips.
The first-- this is season one.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Mars will be risky, dangerous.
But it'll be the greatest
adventure ever, ever
in human history.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Funny thing about Mars--
it feels like Earth.
But it is more hostile to
life than any place on Earth.
- Ignition.
- In the absence of gravity,
lots of things can go wrong.
- It's an unknown.
And you're basically allowing
yourself to be an experiment.
- We're coming in too fast.
- Warning-- landing hazard.
- [INAUDIBLE] just firing.
- Hang on!
- Ben?
Can you hear me?
- The question is, will
you be able to survive
during this crucial
time of arrival?
- Ben, we're losing him.
We're losing him!
- These people are
putting their bodies
at risk for us,
for the human race.
- When we get to Mars, we need
protection from radiation.
- Unmanned aerial vehicle ready.
- We'll use a fleet of
drones to find a lava
tube with the conditions
we need to deploy
a small domed habitat.
- And that little
foothold will become
humankind's first real
home beyond the gravity
well, Olympus Town.
- If I push this
modification any farther,
we risk overloading the
entire electrical system.
- We don't have
a choice, Robert.
- Fire!
- What did you do?
[SCREAMS]
- If the topography is
right and the ice is there,
we can justify deployment.
- I hope you're not
scared of the dark.
[LAUGHS]
- If there was water on
Mars, couldn't there possibly
be life?
- There's [INAUDIBLE].
We're home.
- Medical lab is
now operational.
- The greenhouse is complete.
- We at MMC feel that
we're ready to go faster.
Phase two expansion will be
overseen by the very best.
Our dream is now a reality.
- They don't know Mars.
You guys up for a
welcoming committee?
Base commander, Hana Seung.
- Within two months,
we'll have enough power
to double the size and
capacity of your facilities.
- It's a little too
ambitious right now.
- You don't go to
Mars without ambition.
- I don't think we're going
to get a chance to get
that reactor back online.
- If you got a dust storm
that lasted for a month,
you'd be in big trouble.
- This storm has been
raging for months.
They call it a season.
- I can't do my job.
- Who is going to have
a real problem in space?
Ultimately, there
are some people
who are going to have
a really hard time.
- The swarm is
getting to everyone.
Are you missing home?
- I'm OK.
- He lives for his work.
And he can't do it.
Darling?
- This is Paul Richardson.
- What is he doing?
- Greenhouse air
lock compromised.
- Seal the door!
- As we buried our friends,
the fate of the mission
was back on Earth.
- If you send astronauts
to Mars and they die there,
public opinion will prohibit
you from ever doing it again.
- It's a time to be strong,
to make a statement that
says we're here to stay.
- Seven of the world's
most beloved scientists
and astronauts are dead.
You're not going to
influence my recommendation
to the committee.
- When we thought it could only
get darker, there was light.
- We have been talking
about life on Mars forever.
- Looks like
[INAUDIBLE] crystal.
Javier and I found something.
- Just think about what it would
mean if you found a single cell
microorganism.
- Today marks the end of an era
and the beginning of a new one.
- It would be so exciting
to wake up in the morning
and think that that's
what's happening.
- There is life on Mars.
- They're here.
- Commander, incoming debris.
Commander!
Are you OK?
- Get down!
- I have big plans
for this planet.
- We're not scientists,
for God's sake.
We're miners.
- With the advancement of
sciences comes industry.
- We need to hook up your
water and your power.
- Sorry?
- [INAUDIBLE] says is becoming
irrelevant on your watch.
- Mars, private enterprise--
yes, it's inevitable.
- When we talk about
what we're doing on Mars,
we're really talking
about what we
think is OK to do
here on this planet.
- What's that saying?
Drill, baby, drill?
- I myself have struck a
deal with Lukrum Industries.
Give the miners what they want.
- Yes, they're doing a job.
But they also are creating
lives for themselves.
- I came here for the adventure.
- I'm pregnant.
It's not like I planned it.
- No.
You just plan to leave.
- If we go to Mars, you
don't want any surprises.
- If this baby is born on Mars--
- It could never leave here.
- [INAUDIBLE]
talking [INAUDIBLE]..
- Technology and workers
will be pushed faster
than they should be pushed.
- Let me help you.
- And those errors have
disastrous consequences.
[SCREAMING]
- Coexistence may prove
just as challenging
as it does on Earth.
- Do you see something?
- Only what we're looking for.
- If you think I'm going
to let you and your company
[INAUDIBLE]!
- You're one crazy
bitch, you know that?
[SMACK]
- If there's a place
you've never been,
there's a scientist who
wants to know what's there.
- Companies want access
to new territory.
At the same time, we
have a counter movement
that says we're not going
down without a fight.
- Mars is for those
willing to accept
a much higher level of danger.
- Solar flare.
It's taken out our
electrical grid
and our entire communications.
She could freeze to
death before we find her.
- We've disrupted
the environment,
creating new conditions
where diseases can spread.
- [INAUDIBLE].
- What do we got?
- Something at the site
has been making them sick.
- Stop the drilling.
- When governments are
hiding an outbreak,
that's when the virus
is actually winning.
- I want to know the truth.
- [INAUDIBLE].
- You'd be walking
straight into the source.
- I'm the only one who
knows this science.
- She's not breathing!
I need help!
- He's dead.
- It's my opinion that this
colony requires new leadership.
- Lukrum colony disengaged.
- Olympus Town--
pull the cord or not?
- [INAUDIBLE].
- People would lie,
cheat, and steal
to make sure that the mission
was successful, even if that
cost a lot of human lives.
- I take orders
from my commander.
- You do your job,
and I'll do mine.
- They've taken advantage
of us at every turn.
And you've let it happen.
- Will we make mistakes on mars?
Yes.
[SCREAMING]
- We have nothing
to show for it.
- You see something that
has unimaginable wealth.
And you want to go get it.
- And we're getting water today.
Initiating final prep
before detonation.
- Lukrum's within hours
of reaching water.
- Space exploration is
where we solve problems that
have never been solved before.
- Are you OK with
what he's doing?
- Go.
- I came here to find life.
But not at the expense of it.
- Nothing is a clean slate.
We impose ourselves
on everything.
- [INAUDIBLE].
- The future of humanity is
very much in the solar system.
What kind of civilizations
are we going to build?
[END PLAYBACK]
BOBBY BRAUN: So what
you saw there was just
a brief recap of
season one, which
was all about the
initial settlement,
the scientific undertaking
that that initial settlement
was about, basic survival
in that settlement.
And then, in season
two, the expansion,
the inevitable expansion as
industry comes in and some
of the personal challenges
and conflicts that
arise between science objectives
and industry objectives.
Many of which play out in
this world all the time--
that we are, you
know, portraying
in the future on Mars.
And so with that as kind of
background, we could start Q&A.
And so I actually have
a question prepared
for each of the panelists.
But you are welcome to
ask questions as well.
I might give you
a little heads up
that we're going to be asking
the audience for questions
in just a minute.
But let me start--
we'll just go this way.
Let me start with you,
Stephen, if that's OK.
STEPHEN PETRANEK:
Depends on the question.
BOBBY BRAUN: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
We'll talk about
terraforming later.
STEPHEN PETRANEK: All right.
BOBBY BRAUN: But
let's start out just
by talking about what
it's like for you
personally to see this
creation put together
by this wonderful team of
actors, and writers, producers,
all based on that relatively
small book that you wrote--
very important,
but small in size--
book that you wrote.
How does that feel?
And how do you
think the portrayal
has gone in terms of accuracy?
STEPHEN PETRANEK:
Well, I have a mic.
Good.
Well, it was a big shock.
I've been a science
journalist my whole life.
And I've never been
kind of buffered up
against the Hollywood syndrome.
So when we first got involved
in this project and the book
was first optioned
by RadicalMedia,
there were all kinds
of twists and turns
that were kind of crazy,
like getting SpaceX
to cooperate with
us, which was a very
difficult problem initially.
And then, seeing how this
concept of storytelling
was far more important to
anyone on the West Coast
than the facts were to anyone
on the East Coast, where I was.
So there was kind of this
thing going on between us.
And my role quickly became
not just explaining,
as was Bobby's role,
initially, in the show,
not just explaining
to the filmmaking
people and the
actors and so forth
what the real facts
were about being
on Mars and the kinds of
scenarios you could have
and you couldn't have.
For example, I will
never forget a phone call
from the director
in the first season.
And we were talking about
actually leaving Earth
and going to Mars and the trip.
And they said, OK,
somebody's gotta die on this.
How are they going to die?
So I gave them,
like, five scenarios.
And my favorite scenario
was that a small meteoroid
would pass through the rocket.
And they said no,
we don't like that.
And then I gave them a
couple other scenarios.
No, we don't like that.
And I gave them a couple--
no, I don't like that.
And it was, like, well,
wait a minute, you know?
What kind of
scenario do you want?
And they would
give me one, and I
would say that isn't
physically possible in space.
So initially, there was a lot
of conflict and buffering,
trying to come up--
trying to get the people who
wanted to do the storytelling
and were very good at it to
adapt to the physical realities
of the universe.
[LAUGHTER]
But in the end, it
worked out great.
And one of the things
that really surprised me
was that both the
actors and the directors
were really eager to learn.
Like, when I first met the
initial group of actors,
every single one of
them had read the book.
Some of them had read the
book two or three times.
And the book served
as kind of a primer,
because it kind of laid
out all the facts of what
it would be like on Mars, what
it would be like getting there.
What if, you know, it's
very science-based and very
fact-based.
And they really absorbed that
and wanted to learn that.
So it's been a lot of fun.
And I've learned an awful lot.
You know, I thought, as a
journalist and as a writer
and as an editor--
and you know, I used to be
kind of a writer's editor
who worked with really
long form kind of stories
that you would--
the kind of stories
you would see in "The New
Yorker" or "The New York Times
Sunday Magazine."
I thought I knew
everything that I was ever
going to need to know
about storytelling.
And this new dimension, which is
visual, taught me an awful lot.
And it taught me an
awful lot about scene
setting in words, as
well as in visuals
and carrying
through a storyline.
So I'm very grateful for
the whole experience.
BOBBY BRAUN: Thank you.
Thanks.
Antonia, first of all, welcome
back to Boulder, your hometown.
ANTONIA JUHASZ: I'm from here.
It's nice to be back.
BOBBY BRAUN: That's great.
ANTONIA JUHASZ: Yeah.
BOBBY BRAUN: You play a
extremely important role
in season two as one
of the big thinkers.
And in fact, your
insights in the show,
you know, personally, I
have found fascinating,
the drilling on Mars, drilling
on Earth kind of parallels
and challenges in that vein.
Can you talk a little
bit more about how
you view what we're doing
today, presently, to the Earth
and on the Earth--
how you view that playing
out in the future on Mars?
ANTONIA JUHASZ: Yeah.
It is great to be home.
I live in San Francisco now.
But I grew up in Boulder.
So it's really great
to be back here
and see the brand new campus
and thanks for all of you
for being here.
So as you saw in the previews,
what's really exciting--
one of the things that's really
exciting about the show is I do
think this model is
entirely unique and a just
revolutionary way of
storytelling-- which
is the hybrid of the
documentary and the drama.
So they're interlaced,
as you saw.
You've got the dramatic
series in the future on Mars.
And then you have
the documentary.
And you go back and
forth between the two,
and both sets become
characters, in a way.
You want to know, I
think, not only what's
going to happen to the
characters in the drama,
but what the next big
thinker is going to say.
Because you also become
invested in them,
because they're carried
through this storyline,
the documentary
storyline, as well.
But in the first
season, the documentary
is basically about the
science of getting to Mars.
In the second season,
the documentary
is really about what are
the unforeseen consequences
that we've treated as
unforeseen consequences
on Earth that have led us to
a devastation of our ability
to cohabitate with this planet?
And will we follow
those same failures
as we go to the next planet?
And trying to learn
those lessons--
and that's basically,
from my perspective,
or at least my role in the
documentary, my role is about--
is looking at the failure of
resource extraction on Earth
and will the failure of
be carried forward?
And the failure of resource
extraction on Earth
is really well-embodied
in oil extraction.
And so that's sort of
the tool that's followed.
In season two, as
you saw, Greenpeace
is followed as they
go head to head
with oil drilling in the
Arctic, with the outcome of oil
drilling in the Yamal
Peninsula of the Russian Arctic
and in the drilling platform
in the Norwegian Arctic.
And I think what is really some
of the crux of the storyline
and how I have
summarized the two
seasons from my own perspective
is the first season is looking
at will Mars kill the
humans that go there,
and the second season is
will the humans kill Mars.
And that is looking at
what's going to happen when
and if this major
industry comes.
And the depiction of the
industry in Lukrum Industries
is really incredibly spot
on-- in the way it's written,
in the portrayal of the actors,
in the difficulties they face
and the decision to--
as Jeff, who's the actor
in the clip, says--
"drill, baby, drill",
quoting Sarah Palin.
And I think that the
lessons are really
well-embodied in
both sets of stories.
One of the critical
issues that's
raised, is there life on Mars--
one of the big challenges that
happens with oil drilling,
and what one sees over
and over and over again
with oil drilling, the
history of the last 150 years
of oil drilling, is the
drilling goes first and only
afterwards do we
then learn, oh, wait.
There was this really
critical natural resource.
There was this group of
people who lived here.
There are all sorts of
consequences that only get
thought of as an afterthought.
And one of the best examples
of that in Arctic drilling,
which I think is a good parallel
to what could happen on Mars,
is something that seems
really inconsequential,
and that's phytoplankton.
It just looks like a seaweed.
But it turns out
that phytoplankton,
if you destroy it--
it provides 50% of the oxygen
we need to live on the planet.
So treating it as a sort
of inconsequential thing
is one of the reasons why we're
facing the problem that we're
facing right now.
And so trying to
learn the lesson,
which is maybe consider
the consequences first,
the long-term consequences
first, and just go in--
go in second with the blind
pursuit of the resource.
BOBBY BRAUN: That's great.
Thank you.
Leonard, so great for you
to be here today, Leonard.
So our interaction dates back
to actual spaceflight missions,
right?
And I'm typically used to seeing
Leonard David articles written
about InSight or
about Mars 2020.
LEONARD DAVID: He's so happy
I spelled his name right.
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY BRAUN: Mars-- all the
way back to Mars Pathfinder
in the '90s, right?
So I'm very interested in your
opinion of this show, which
is a portrayal of
a future mission,
because I know that you've
very accurately covered
so many existing missions.
Can you comment on that briefly?
LEONARD DAVID: Well, you know,
I think one thing that strikes
me, the drill, baby, drill
thing-- before I forget--
that's also a Chris McKay line.
He's a Mars scientist.
And he wants to drill
subsurface to look for life.
So it's-- and the
atmosphere is changing.
I love that subtitle.
Because this morning I got
up, and I looked at InSight.
We just landed on
Mars a few days ago.
OSIRIS-REx pulls up at
an asteroid yesterday.
The Japanese space agency
has another asteroid mission
that's also on target.
Three people left the
Earth the other day
to head to the Space Station.
SpaceX just hurled out 60-some
satellites out of one rocket
and then flew the booster back.
And I think that's
atmosphere changing.
I've never seen so much
activity in the last week.
And something's going on here.
And it's not just NASA,
but it's a global effort.
And when you think about
what's coming from Mars,
we have Mars 2020.
The NASA super cute
Curiosity Rover--
that will take off in 2020.
China is going to launch a
Mars mission, a robotic Mars
mission, same time period.
UAE-- they're going to be
launching a Mars orbiter.
And it's absolutely
incredible what's happening.
And Mars is-- it's dangerous.
It's destiny, you know, for me.
I've always felt that Mars was--
from a kid, covering
early Mars missions,
Viking particularly in 1976--
that was just a thrill.
The first pictures come back.
Of course, you're
looking, you want
to see rabbits running
around out there or whatever.
And I just remember that
one guy, I think it was--
I can't remember his name now.
But he-- there's rocks!
They have rocks on Mars!
OK.
Not quite rabbits, but it
was good enough for me.
But yeah, the future is now.
I just I really--
honest to God, the
last week and a half,
how many things have happened?
Unbelievable.
BOBBY BRAUN: It's true.
I mean, it's a whole new era
of space exploration right now.
In the US, it's not only
the government, right?
There's companies that are
doing things on their own.
It's incredible.
So let's see what kind of
questions you all have for us.
Anybody want to go first?
AUDIENCE: Less of a
technology question,
but I was just curious where you
do the majority of your filming
and how much is CGI versus how
much is actual physical sets?
STEPHEN PETRANEK:
There's $15 million
worth of sets in
Budapest right now.
They're all packaged up.
They were in a
container building,
as typical of Hollywood
sets, that you could have
parked about seven 747s in.
We built the largest
green screen ever
in the history of movie making
so that we could go to Morocco
and photograph where NASA rovers
are tested because it actually
looks like and is a lot
like the surface of Mars.
Then project that on the
screen and have the actors
in front of that screen.
It's kind of remarkable
stuff that they've done.
They built full-size sets.
For the first season when I
was walking through the sets,
I mean, you really
can begin to think
you're on Mars in
just a few minutes
because things are so realistic.
Down to there was
a little container
in a hallway in the sets in
the first season on Mars.
And I picked it up
and looked at it.
And it was this container
that supposedly something
had been brought to Mars in.
And it had, like, six different
labels on it, you know,
approved by inspector
such and such in Houston
and stuff like that.
I mean, down to the level that
the camera would never pick up,
these sets were so
elaborate and so exacting
because it allows the
actors to get into the role
and really feel
like they're there.
So we unfortunately lost
our spot in Budapest.
Budapest has now become a very
popular place to make movies,
and many movies that you
think are British or American
are actually made in
Budapest these days.
And we're probably going
to move to Bucharest
for the next season, if there's
a next season, because it's
cheaper to make films there.
But it's pretty elaborate
stuff, you know?
It's the stuff of making
real movies as opposed
to just a documentary series.
So the investment in this
has been extraordinary.
I think for the first
season, the sets were--
there were $5 million
dollars worth of sets.
And for the second season,
they added another $10 million
for the sets.
And the second season,
the sets are just huge
compared to the first season.
And I think if there's a
third and a fourth season,
it will grow in that way.
LEONARD DAVID: Who
decides on that?
How does that happen?
[INAUDIBLE]
STEPHEN PETRANEK: Vice
presidents at Fox.
ANTONIA JUHASZ: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY BRAUN: There's a
question in the middle there?
AUDIENCE: So we've been
imagining Mars colonization
for years and years and years.
Thinking about today, what
things, challenges had we
anticipated before that we're
now better able to deal with?
And what new challenges
have we discovered that we
didn't foresee back then?
STEPHEN PETRANEK:
That's probably for you.
BOBBY BRAUN: Well, I'll start.
But you can always add in.
So I would argue that we've made
great progress in determining
how to land big things on Mars.
So this is an area that I've
worked in most of my career.
And if you had asked
me 10 years ago
how we were going to land humans
on Mars, I would have said,
you know, I don't know.
There were a lot of ideas
out there 10 years ago
or even 20 years ago.
There were a lot
of cartoon drawings
that showed how
one might do that.
But none of that
technology had been proven.
And recently, actually
here on the Earth,
we've done a lot to
prove those technologies.
So one example
would be when SpaceX
returns these first stage
boosters that they've
done successfully over
30 times now, way up high
in the atmosphere when they're
bringing that booster back,
they call out something
called an entry burn.
And that burn takes
place supersonically
in Mars-relevant conditions.
Because you're up
so high, you're
up around 100,000 feet or higher
when that burn takes place.
And what they're
doing is they're
firing their jets in opposite to
the direction of the velocity.
So opposing free stream.
And that's something
that actually people
have talked about a lot.
But until SpaceX had
a need to do that,
no one had ever done that
in Mars-relevant conditions.
And as I've said,
they've done it--
for a big piece of
hardware, they've
done it 30 times or
more successfully.
You don't see that because
it happens so high.
You see the booster coming
down right on the drone ship.
And that's exciting, too.
But for those of us that
are focused on Mars,
we care about what happened at
40 kilometers or so altitude.
Also, through the
robotic program--
I mean, I started my career
by landing Mars Pathfinder
on the surface.
It landed a little rover
called Sojourner that
was about the size of a baby.
It was 11 kilograms in mass.
And you know, Mars
Science Laboratory is
the size of a small car, right?
It's a nuclear powered
car with a laser on it.
[LAUGHTER]
Right?
That we landed in 2012--
and by the way, in
2020, we're going
to land much more accurately.
We're going to land
basically in a football field
instead of in a 20
kilometer safe zone.
So that kind of
accuracy is required
to build up a base camp, right?
In the series, you see that
there have been many landings.
And in order to build
up this base camp
those many landings have to
happen in close proximity
to each other to get all
that hardware together.
And that's a technology
that we're improving.
I think our ability to
keep people alive, frankly,
and to keep them safe so that
they can live, play, and work
in space, both in the
microgravity environment
of space and on
another planet, has
been greatly advanced
by what we're
doing on the International
Space Station today.
Leonard mentioned the three
astronauts that just went.
But they joined three others
that are already there.
And we've had people
from our planet in space
continuously since 2001.
Think about that.
Not the same people,
but I mean, that's
a remarkable achievement
for our planet.
And it's not just
Americans, right?
There are international
astronauts included in that.
And to think that we've
lived off of our world
continuously, some
small subset of us
have done so continuously
and safely since 2001,
that tells you something about
the reliability of the system
the crew systems needed
to keep people safe,
about food processing, about
water processing, radiation
shielding.
All of the kinds of
technologies that you see
played out in this series,
they're happening today.
And then the last piece
that I'll mention,
and I'll see if you
want to add to that--
STEPHEN PETRANEK: Correct.
BOBBY BRAUN: --is really--
correct-- is just the
advancement of industry,
frankly, in this country.
It's one thing
for our government
to be talking about sending
humans back to the moon.
It's a great, exciting
thing to repeat
something like the Apollo
missions from the 1960s.
It would be a fantastic
achievement for our country.
But what really impresses
me and gets me going,
gets my juices going, is
the industry capabilities
in this country at
places like SpaceX,
or you know, right here in
Colorado at Lockheed Martin,
or what's going on with Blue
Origin or Virgin Galactic,
all of these companies
that are on their own
contributing to
the space economy.
Planet Labs, that is
basically building
almost a real-time
Google Earth, right?
You know, it's remarkable
what's happening in space today.
And I think that capability is
required for us to efficiently
and cost effectively go to Mars.
STEPHEN PETRANEK: I think from
a technical point of view,
one of the most interesting
things about going to Mars
is that most of the technology
that you needed to do this
has been available
for at least 30 years.
I'd like to say 40 years,
but probably 30 years.
There's a device on the
new Curiosity rover that's
going up in 2020 called MOXIE
that will split the carbon
atom off the CO2
atmosphere of Mars
and create enough oxygen for
one human being to breathe
consistently, for example.
That machine is
supposed to be scaled,
is designed to be scaled
up by a factor of 100.
I think NASA originally
wanted that machine
so that they could have
an oxidizer on Mars
to make rocket fuel for a
return trip in the future.
But in fact, that
machine is probably
going to turn out to
be the machine that
makes the oxygen that people
need to breathe on Mars.
I'm not quite sure
what they're going
to use for the rest of the
inert gas, the other 78%.
That is still a
technical problem.
But what's amazing
is that all this
stuff-- you know, we made this
decision to stay in Earth orbit
a long, long time ago, as
the Apollo program was coming
to an end and we decided to
build a space shuttle, which
is supposed to be
cheap and reusable
and turned out to cost about
over a billion for each flight.
And we have not
kind of reached out
and extended what
we're capable of doing.
We haven't gone back
to the moon, which I
think would be kind of a waste.
But we haven't taken
a bold step like we
did in the Apollo
program and decided
to let's just go to Mars.
And yet we've had
this capability
to do this for so long.
And to touch on one other thing
that both Leonard and Bobby
have touched on.
Space is the next big business.
It isn't an accident that you
see all these things happening
in the last week or so.
The Russians have
committed to going to Mars
and putting a human on Mars.
The Chinese have committed
to putting a human on Mars.
Both the Russians
and the Chinese
have committed to put
humans on the moon again.
NASA has committed just recently
to putting humans on the moon
again.
And yet, as Bobby says, there
are all these private companies
that could actually
do it maybe even
before any of these
governments could do it,
companies like SpaceX, which
actually intend to do it
before a government does it.
This is the next big business.
Lassoing the SLS launch
system and the Orion capsule
that NASA has built, one
of the original things
they wanted to do
with that literally
was to go out and find a
near-Earth asteroid and lasso
it and bring it back and put
it in orbit around the moon
so that commercial companies
could practice mining it.
That's real!
That's real technology
that we have now
that we're capable of doing.
It's just going to be mind
blowing how this stuff expands.
And it's expanding a lot because
of the commercial aspects
of space.
It's really going to
be a big business.
ANTONIA JUHASZ: I think that's
the perfect place to chime in.
I think that what is
happening very rapidly
is the movement towards securing
ownership of resources, who's
going to own the resources.
And the only existing
international architecture
was the moon treaty--
STEPHEN PETRANEK:
'67 space treaty.
ANTONIA JUHASZ: Outer
space 1967 treaty.
And the goal was to not
have a militarized space.
That was the goal
of that treaty.
It was a peace treaty.
Now it's being written,
our attempts-- there's
already national
legislation that's
happened in the United
States and other attempts
that are being written
to define ownership
of what you would mine
in space, who owns it,
who gets to profit from it.
And that's all being
driven right now
by private companies, period.
And that is a
similar model, which
is will the private companies
gain ownership of asteroids
and the rights to mine
asteroids and other planets
and what they get there
and how they do it?
And will a regulatory regime
only catch up afterwards,
after it's happening?
And if that happens, are
the unintended consequences
of mining asteroids
being thought
through by the people who are
intending to do the mining?
Or will that be an afterthought?
So Osiris-REx,
one of its goals--
this is the mission that
Leonard just mentioned--
that just yesterday
successfully--
STEPHEN PETRANEK:
Got to [INAUDIBLE]..
It does--
ANTONIA JUHASZ: Got there.
STEPHEN PETRANEK:
--recovery [? route. ?]
ANTONIA JUHASZ:
One of its goals is
to determine the viability
of asteroid mining.
That's one of the intentions.
And so for someone
like me, who has
spent her career looking at
this sort of the industry
goes forward and sort
of regulation's attempt
to follow afterwards, and what
the consequences of those are,
thinking about it now for me
in this entirely new realm
which is all of space.
And what the unintended
consequences could be
is truly profound.
And trying to
encourage the public
to participate in this
process as much as industry
is before the cat gets much
further out of the bag.
LEONARD DAVID: There's
some kind of line,
and I don't think
I came up with it.
I stole it from
somebody, probably.
But you do the peaceful
uses of outer space.
And then somebody
says, the useful--
how does this go?
Now I can't remember
what I'm talking about.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
Useful pieces of outer space.
ANTONIA JUHASZ: Yeah.
That works.
LEONARD DAVID: And
that's interesting.
One little, quick short story.
I used to go--
every time there
was a Mars mission,
I'd go to JPL ahead of time,
go talk to all the engineers.
And one time I went in there,
and this was on Pathfinder.
The head guy goes and puts me in
his office and shuts the door.
And he says, if this fails, how
will you guys report on this?
And I said, well, how is
this really going to work?
He said, we're using airbags--
airbags.
OK, let's see how that one goes.
But that mission
was the first time
I ever heard of
co-location, which
is what you folks do here.
And that was why it succeeded.
They had people co-located
in the same buildings
to talk to each other.
People that were working
on a parachute for a month
would all of a sudden be going
over to another part of--
the wheels of the rover.
Each person learned more
about their spacecraft.
But that was called co-location.
And then I went back
a couple years ago,
before Curiosity landed.
How are you going to land that?
Oh, a sky crane--
it'll be dropped
down on a tether.
And you're going--
I'm still buying
drinks on that one.
Because I--
[LAUGHTER]
BOBBY BRAUN: All right.
I can't wait to [INAUDIBLE].
LEONARD DAVID: That
is not going to work!
BOBBY BRAUN: Yeah.
Yeah.
LEONARD DAVID: And that
to me, that partnership
that has to develop between
people in these missions
to make things happen
is baton passing,
space age baton passing.
And each person
contributes to the whole.
And it's pretty
amazing to watch.
AUDIENCE: What work needs to
be done before we can actually
send humans to Mars?
STEPHEN PETRANEK: Not
much of anything--
it's a problem of money.
Musk estimates that
it's $36 billion--
$35-36 billion to land
the first humans on Mars.
He doesn't have $36 billion.
If he did, I think he'd
probably start launching
cargo missions this year.
You need about
three cargo missions
to land successfully on Mars.
Bobby and a lot of
people from NASA
think the first cargo landing
that SpaceX attempts on Mars
will probably fail.
And they think that
they will learn--
BOBBY BRAUN: Not probably.
STEPHEN PETRANEK:
Well, a lot of--
a lot of people that
I've talked to at NASA
seem to think it
will probably fail.
BOBBY BRAUN: If you're
going to state my opinion,
I'm going to jump in there.
STEPHEN PETRANEK: All right.
All right.
BOBBY BRAUN: So what I've said
is that if you need three,
you should send four.
STEPHEN PETRANEK: Right.
BOBBY BRAUN: Just before
you send the humans.
Because one of them may--
STEPHEN PETRANEK: May.
BOBBY BRAUN: --fail.
Go ahead.
STEPHEN PETRANEK:
But anyway, there's
a lot to be learned from
those failures, extraordinary.
I mean, you probably learn, if
you have a successful landing
and part of it is luck, that's
not a learning experience.
If you have a failure and you
learn a lot from the failure,
and then you don't make
the same mistakes again,
things work a lot
better in the future.
So what I suspect is going
to happen is that, as soon--
if Tesla becomes as
successful as it should be,
if Musk is able to launch
7,000 communications satellites
and offer you data and voice
for $9.95 a month and capture--
there are 10 billion
Wi-Fi connected devices
on the planet, more
than there are people.
If he gets a fourth of that
or a fifth of that population,
two billion, and he gets
$10 a month from everybody,
he's going to quickly have the
money to launch people to Mars.
So this is really a
money problem and not
a technology problem.
Just as we threw money
at Apollo in the '60s,
4% of the GDP of the United
States went into that program.
Now about 1/16 of the GDP of the
United States goes into NASA.
If you were to throw
those kind of resources
into landing people
on Mars, there
would definitely be people
on Mars within 10 years.
AUDIENCE: So Elon
Musk has recently
said that SpaceX
will land people
on Mars in the next six years.
What are your thoughts
on that timeline?
As a subquestion,
what do you think
is a more realistic
timeline for that to happen?
STEPHEN PETRANEK: I think
they're kind of different.
When I originally wrote my
book, Musk told me 2024, 2025.
And I said come on.
And he said, look.
If we haven't landed
people on Mars by 2030,
I will be deeply disappointed.
And he meant deeply
disappointed,
the kind of failure
that he doesn't accept.
He recently walked
back his statement
on when the first
humans would be on Mars.
He recently said--
I don't think many
people noticed this.
But he was asked in an interview
when the first people would
land on Mars.
And he said the thing he's been
saying recently, which is 2024.
And then he said,
well, at least I'm
certain we'll have a
cargo mission by 2024.
And that was a real walk back.
Because he said
I'm not sure we'll
have people on Mars in 2024,
which is what he's been saying.
But I'm sure we'll
have a cargo mission.
So give it a couple years.
Maybe the first cargo
mission is 2026.
Next cargo mission is 2028.
Then 2030 you have
a cargo mission.
And maybe simultaneously
you have two rockets going
and you have a crew landing.
That would be the estimate that
I would give you right now.
LEONARD DAVID: There's
a catch-22 in all this,
and it is the life
on Mars question.
There's going to be,
probably, some new information
about methane detection on Mars.
And that's going to be a very
interesting possible connection
for biology.
The other thing
that's happening,
and there's a lot of concern
about planetary protection
and the coordination of
international groups.
And Elon tossed his
Tesla out there.
And that was not a happy moment
for the planetary protection
people, although it didn't get
near Mars or some flew past it.
But there was a problem.
And there is a real--
I think there's going
to be a headlong battle
between planetary
protection people
and the life detection people
and privatization of Mars.
So I'd watch that one.
That's going to come.
And we'll see.
But the lawyers thing
is the greatest.
It's a head on collision.
It's just going to be wild.
I mean, it's the Wild
West sort of thing.
But I think that's
going to be another one.
I've just finished writing up.
And I had to go talk
to a lot of lawyers.
And you can have
the rolodex of pro,
con, no, we shouldn't
do this and that.
So we got some
real issues coming.
ANTONIA JUHASZ: I mean, I
think the other issue that
is being addressed in two
separate questions instead
of one is this issue of where
the Outer Space Treaty was--
a peace treaty was the intention
of it-- was a peace treaty.
And how significantly more
advanced at this point
weaponization of
space-- and money,
when you're talking
about money--
the US defense space
budget, so the space budget
of the defense
industry, not NASA
was $45 billion dollars the
last time it was identified,
and that was in 2015.
So there's a lot of money there.
And then where and how is
the overlap being discussed
as we move much more
quickly towards Mars
and the amount of money
that's needed to do that?
And where the money
currently resides,
which is in the defense
industry and weaponization--
will there be a marriage?
That many people who for a long
time sought peace in space,
you know, have fought to prevent
LEONARD DAVID: That's why
we need the Space Force.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ANTONIA JUHASZ: That's why
we have the Space Force.
BOBBY BRAUN: Let me
just-- before you
jump on that, one
second-- so I'd just
add that when you try to
define a timeline for when
the first humans
will be on Mars,
it depends a great deal
on what the strategy is
for those humans.
So it actually wouldn't
be that hard to just send
a couple of humans to Mars, have
them be there for a few weeks,
you know, a la Apollo, and
then have them come back.
And we could certainly, as
a country, if we chose to,
we could do that in the 2020s.
STEPHEN PETRANEK:
But we would probably
do an Apollo 8 kind of
thing and go into orbit
and come back and
not actually land.
BOBBY BRAUN: Well,
we could do both.
STEPHEN PETRANEK: Yeah.
BOBBY BRAUN: But in the series,
what we've chosen to do,
if you notice, it's many of the
same astronauts from season one
are still there in season two--
Sammi, as an example.
And so if you're thinking
about the first humans going
to settle Mars, which is
the way SpaceX and Elon Musk
talk about this, there
are many more cargo ships.
There's much more of a
base camp environment that
needs to be built up and
a lot more infrastructure.
And so in my view, you're
talking about the 2030s
by the time you would
send those humans because
of all the emplacement
of the infrastructure
that has to go first.
LEONARD DAVID:
One good thing was
when I got the word
to do this Mars book,
I was at a conference
at Johnson Space Center.
They brought in all
these scientists.
And for the first
time in one room,
people sat around and
talked about where do we--
STEPHEN PETRANEK:
Where do we land?
LEONARD DAVID: --yeah,
where do we land,
and where can this base be?
And then the exploration
zones were being drawn out.
I mean--
BOBBY BRAUN: There's been
real discussion of this.
LEONARD DAVID: Yeah,
this is moving ahead.
BOBBY BRAUN: There's
a question back here.
AUDIENCE: So I
apologize if you're
fed up with this question.
Were you influenced at
all by Andy Weir's book,
"The Martian" in the series?
And then vise
versa, do you think
he was influenced by your work?
And what did you
think of the science?
STEPHEN PETRANEK: I
have a personal story
about that, which is in--
my book came out in
2015, in July of 2015.
In April of 2015, I had been
asked to do a TED talk on Mars.
And I did this talk.
I've done two other TED talks
on the main stage with TED.
They were both greeted by
wild applause, and people
standing up and everything.
And this one was treated
with polite applause.
And I walked off the
stage, and I thought,
what the hell happened here?
Jeff Bezos had a
dinner that night
in which he basically tried to
criticize every single thing I
had said about
people going to Mars,
and how this was a PR
campaign by Elon Musk
to gain more attention
for Tesla and so forth.
And the people who ran TED--
the guy who runs TED is
a close friend of mine--
said we're not putting
your talk up online.
And then in September,
"The Martian" came out.
So my book came
out, wasn't selling.
"The Martian" came out.
I had sat down with
Charlie Bolden when
I was writing the book and
talked about NASA's plans
for humans landing on Mars.
And he took me to one
of the 10,000 pages,
obscure pages of NASA that
said in big bold type,
NASA has no plans
for a human mission
to Mars, right there
on their website.
"Martian" comes out.
All of a sudden, my book
starts selling like crazy.
TED decides to put
my talk up online.
Charlie Bolden appoints a
director of a manned mission
to Mars.
Didn't have any staff, but--
so that's how much influence a
Hollywood movie had on society.
It actually convinced people
that this was a possibility.
If Matt Damon can
do it, we can do it.
[LAUGHTER]
ANTONIA JUHASZ: And
there is a dance remix
of Stephen giving the TED talk.
STEPHEN PETRANEK: Oh, God.
BOBBY BRAUN: And
I'll also point out
that Andy participated as
one of the big thinkers--
STEPHEN PETRANEK: Yes.
BOBBY BRAUN: --in season one.
So he was a part of the first
season of the Nat Geo series.
STEPHEN PETRANEK:
And I should mention
that he's gone through kind
of a metamorphosis, too.
He was very defensive
initially about the facts that
were inaccurate in his book.
Like 300 mile an
hour wind on Mars
is not going to drive
a piece of an antenna
through your spacesuit
kind of thing.
In fact, you could walk through
a 300 mile an hour wind on Mars
easily.
It would be like a three
mile an hour wind on Earth.
And he was very
defensive about that.
And then he got
involved in season one.
And you know, some
of us were kind
of beating up on him
about that kind of stuff.
And then season two came around.
And we beat up on him some more.
And now he's very open about
what was wrong in the book.
BOBBY BRAUN: He's a great guy.
STEPHEN PETRANEK:
He's a great guy.
BOBBY BRAUN: Yeah.
All right.
So I'm told that
we're out of time.
But I want to thank you all
for joining us here today.
I'd highly encourage you
to check out the series.
Season two is continuing.
You can check out
episode five next Monday
at 9:00 PM on the
Nat Geo channel.
And I want to also--
in addition to
thanking our panelists,
I want to thank Google--
STEPHEN PETRANEK: Yes.
BOBBY BRAUN: --for welcoming us.
Thank you very much.
STEPHEN PETRANEK: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]